sprechen wir über die angeschlagene
Innenministerin wenn sie das denn schon
ist mit Philipp Amthor Mitglied des
Innenausschusses des Deutschen
Bundestages und Mitglied der
cdu/csu-fraktion Wahlkreis
Mecklenburgische Seenplatte 1 Vorpommern
Greifswald 2 hallo Herr Anton
guten Tag Herr Bauer warum ist das eine
gute Idee von Frau Faeser in Hessen als
Spitzenkandidatin anzutreten und
gleichzeitig
bundesinnenministerin zu bleiben
also es ist natürlich keine gute Idee
sondern es ist in zweierlei Hinsicht
eine schlechte Idee von der cafesa es
ist zum einen eine Hypothek für das Amt
der bundesinnenministerin das ist aber
auch ein Zeichen fehlenden Einsatzes für
Hessen das Amt der bundesinnenministerin
ist kein Teilzeitjob gerade in diesen
Zeiten das sagen selbst die Kollegen aus
der Koalition der Ministerin völlig
zutreffend es braucht die volle
Aufmerksamkeit gerade in der aktuellen
Sicherheitslage auf das Amt der
Bundesministerin und auch Hessen hätte
volle Aufmerksamkeit verdient denn man
muss schon deutlich sagen Hessen das
macht man nicht nebenbei dafür braucht
es Vorhinein etwa unser
Ministerpräsident Boris rein dort zeigt
auf den komme ich gleich noch mal ganz
kurz und machen wir das chronologisch
volle Aufmerksamkeit für das Ministerium
glauben Sie also das Frau Faser keine
volle Aufmerksamkeit ihre Ministerium
geben kann wenn sie gleichzeitig ja
nicht den ganzen Tag über Wahlkampf in
Hessen macht
ich glaube jedenfalls es bräuchte vollen
Einsatz insbesondere für die aktuelle
migrationspolitische Lage wir sehen dass
die Kommunen nicht nur in Hessen sondern
auch in meiner Heimat
entwicklungsvorpommern in ganz
Deutschland unter dem großen Druck
gesteuerten Migration im Moment zu
leiden haben und da sehen wir sehr sehr
deutlich dass es hier eben mehr Handel
mehr Aufmerksamkeit der Innenminister
gebräuchte sie redet die Probleme
stattdessen im Moment klein sagt man
solle keine migrationskrise herbewegen
doch in Wahrheit stecken die Kommunen
mittendrin und ich kann mir kaum
vorstellen dass ich eine Ministerin dann
eher irgendwelchen Wahlkampfauftritten
in Hessen und nicht diesen Problemen das
ist aus meiner Sicht keine richtige
Schwerpunkt setzen
Punkt und sie haben mir ihren
Ministerpräsident schon angesprochen
Boris rein der aktuelle
Ministerpräsident von ihrer Partei der
CDU der wird doch in Hessen auch
Wahlkampf machen und weiter sogar ein
ganzes Bundesland führen müssen wo ist
da der Unterschied aus ihrer Sicht
also erstens glaube ich liegt der größte
Unterschied zwischen Boris rein und
Nancy Feser in dem persönlichen
Fähigkeiten die hat Google rein nämlich
als Innenminister als Landtagspräsident
und jetzt als Ministerpräsident unter
Beweis gestellt von der
bundesinnenministerin sehen wir
stattdessen dass die migrationslager
nicht in den Griff bekommen und das Haus
auch durch schlechte
Personalentscheidung aus meiner Sicht
nicht gut geführt dass es der erste
Unterschied und hinzu kommt Boris rein
der sagt voller Aufmerksamkeit für
Hessen sowie als Ministerpräsident würde
auch als Wahlkämpfer die ganze Zeit in
Hessen unterwegs seid
haben dann muss man ja schon auch sagen
also er kann ja nicht beides machen
haben sie ja vorhin so erklärt also er
kann nicht sowohl dem gesamten
mindestens der Präsidentenamt und dem
Wahlkampf voll Aufmerksamkeit geben das
wäre ja ihre Logik
nein das ist definitiv vereinbar denn
wenn Sie diese Kritik jetzt anbringen
wollen an Herrn rein dann hätten sie
sinnvollerweise ja jede Kandidatur von
Amtsinhabern von Ministerpräsidenten
Ämtern genau kritisieren
Widerspruch das ist ein qualitativ
erheblicher Unterschied die
bundesinnenministerin die glaubt sie
kann das Beste aus beiden Welten
kombinieren sie glaubt sie kann im Fall
einer Wahl Niederlage dann nach Berlin
angeschlagen zurückgehen Ministerin
bleiben und ich finde das ist auch ein
ziemlich merkwürdiges Bild auf das Amt
der Oppositionsführerin in Hessen dass
sie sonst den Fall einer Wahlen
Niederlage annehmen müsste das ist ja
kein ehrenrühriger Job und da hat man
den Eindruck sie will sich für Hessen
nur dann entscheiden wenn es für die
vollposition reicht und das ist aus
meiner Sicht auch eine unverdiente
Geringschätzung für dieses Bundesland
und das dann noch mal klar zu ziehen
sagen Sie also Ministerinnen und
Minister
offenen parallel keinen Wahlkampf führen
das würde ich mir dann so auch merken
für die nächste Regierung an der dann
die CDU vielleicht wieder beteiligt ist
ministerpräsidentinnen und
Ministerpräsidenten können das aber sehr
wohl
also es geht um zwei unterschiedliche
Ebenen zum einen muss man von der
Innenministerin erwarten dass diese
Entscheidung für Hessen eine
Entscheidung ohne Rückfahrticket ist
also wenn sie sich schon entscheidet das
Amt der bundesinnenministerin zu
behalten bis zum Wahltag dann muss aus
meiner Sicht jedenfalls klar sein und
das schuldet sie eigentlich den Hessen
dass sie dann sagt im Falle der beiden
Niederlage ist mein Herz trotzdem in
diesem Bundesland und ich gehe dann
trotzdem in den Landtag das ist Thema
Nummer eins zum Thema Nummer zwei ist
schon dass man auch nach dem Minister am
selbstdifferenzieren muss dass man neben
einem Wahlkampf führt klar ist dass
jedes Ministeramt unter einer
ministerpräsidentenkandidatur das ist
glaube ich objektiv logisch ein Stück
weit zu leiden hat mit Einschnitten zu
kämpfen hat und ich glaube dass das für
das Amt der bundesinnenministerin in der
aktuellen Sicherheitslage in der
migrationslage in der angespannt
cybersicherheitslage durch den
russischen Angriff nicht vertretbar ist
und insoweit wäre es ehrlicher gewesen
zu sagen ja sie will Ministerpräsidentin
werden sie kandidiert den fokussiert
sich auf diese Kandidatur und die
Aufgaben in Berlin im
Bundesinnenministerium die werden dann
von jemand anderem wahrgenommen aber
diesen hohen Stellenwert die
Sicherheitspolitik den scheint Olaf
Scholz als Bundeskanzler nicht zu sehen
relevant Tor Mitglied im
Innenausschuss des Deutschen Bundestages
cdu/csu-fraktion vielen Dank Kinder
herzlichen Dank Grüße aus Vorpommern
Grüße zurück